If the unthought matter is that being is presence, but time complicates the idea that being is
presence, then fine, I'm cool with that. I get that, and I feel like I got that before I even opened this
book, right? Like, um, but but if I mean if it's anything other than that, I don't understand what
it is, you know? Like, yeah. So time is passing away, which is to say presence is always a residual
effect of a passing away. It's never simply there. Got it? Right, got it 10 years ago. Yeah, you know.
And by the way, got it, got got it from Heidegger, right? I'm not, I'm not, like, dissing Heidegger in
that regard, but I'm just wondering, am I missing something else, or is this just the sort of being
as constituted by its coming to be passing awayness? It is never, you know, simply present. I mean, he never
says that. Like, he never says it's it it can't be simply present because it's passing away, which I
is waiting for a sentence that was just that because it's not like a hard thing to say. Yeah.
Right. I mean, he does allude. Like, he he says stuff similar, maybe in the previous section, where he says
time is by being what it is not, you know, which just it's a kind of a cute turn of phrase, but it points
to what you're saying, like the essence of time is that it doesn't have an essence, or that it doesn't
have a a structure or being, you know? So if it's if it's just that relational, I mean, yeah, you're right.
I think it's just the the sort of relational, you can't even call it a grounds of being that is the
unthought of metaphysics, and I guess I just feel like that's I mean, again, I just feel like that's what
being be being as presence is, always coming to be passing away. Again, I learned it from Heidegger,
right? So so it's not, I mean, I'm basically like criticizing Heidegger for not being Heidegger,
which is absurd. Yeah, you know? It's like, or just kind of glossing his own theory, you know? Not right,
not in an interesting way. Yeah, right, you know? But but for instance, I mean, things like, for instance,
that the whole notion of the past here, um, he doesn't say, he doesn't say, like, look, the past is being
thought as a present that's just past, right? Like, you know, that's the thing that I was waiting for is that
the notion of the past as that frozen entity, you know, is something that is behind me now, is is taking
the past as a present that's just not actual anymore, you know? And that, that's the way I mean it. To me,
that was just a, that he says, you know, like, when we think of presence, the presence is the moment of the
now. The past is what's behind us, and the past is in the future, so it's before us, but I'm like,
yeah, I mean, I think the past is very clearly thought as a presence, right? Like, it's right. It's not the
present tense, it's not the present moment, but the past is conceived as a presence that's just not here
anymore. Right? Um, well he gets at that in in two places and in two ways, right? I mean, the first is when
he turns to Aristotle and Augustine and and tries to even see that in in their work where it's like,
look, the past isn't a non-presence, it's just not a present presence, and it's like, it's it is and it
isn't, you know, in that in the Latin of Augustine, um, on page one oh on 102. So that's the one thing is
that he's suggesting that even within this tradition there is a a way of thinking about the past as not
simply lacking presence. It just doesn't somehow have the fullness, and then you suddenly get into
the great chain of being stuff, but the other passage of thinking about the past as something that's not
simply past an alien is through the eternal return of the same itself, and so but part of the move there
and he has to go through showing to make it is that if we're going to think about being not in terms of
you know, substance, but in terms of will, then the eternal return of of the same uh as a capable of
thinking of and and and orient itself to the past completely differently, right? It would be it would
be really interesting for me because what strikes me immediately is the extent to which Heidegger's
version of the eternal return really relies on it being the eternal return of the same, like it has
to be the return of the same. It can't be the Delusian selection of difference um because it's the only
way that you can will eternally is to have the same thing occur eternally except that I think there's a
fundamental difference between the eternal return of the same um in that kind of cosmological
like the scientific sense that we talked about it over the last couple of episodes where
the return of the same or the return of particular substances identities events whatever the else they
might be, but if you're going to swap out an ontology of substance for an ontology based in
will, then it's not the return. It's not like the same thing is going to happen at some point again
in the future, or the same identity or the same substance will re-coalesce at some point in the
future. It's that the the singularity of a a a past of a moment can be willed eternally. Could it could
It also mean that the the same structure of willing uh eternally returns like in in the figure of revenge
Et cetera like so that the will wills itself in the same way eternally is it but or is that
I mean so okay here's how I understand it the the past, the existence of the past is a problem
for the will because it's a limit case it's something the will can't do anything with again conceived of
as something that is simply past and behind us and I would add there that that's also a problem for the
future in so far as you think of the future as a future set of having pasts right because it doesn't matter
I mean this is his stuff like he's like look science isn't giving us any more time it's giving us less time
in its capacity to measure smaller and smaller units of time as soon as you're dividing up time in terms of
the units of has passed will pass doesn't matter it's become that it's become that calcified thing that
you know the will doesn't have control over anymore or will not have control over anymore so so as I
understand it the goal of the will is eternal and the only way the will fulfills that goal is to will
itself eternally and it can't will itself when it's limited by the it was whether we think that in
terms of an obvious past or Nathaniel's amendment to think of the future the future in that way
so you know like to me I you know it's it's he's starting with a very chunked up ontology
that's then going to proceed as I understand it to kind of blur the chunking um you know so that you
wouldn't have a sort of distinct past you know present future thing yeah that you you have so you
know what the the the um revenge is the result of the will encountering this limit so it only thinks
in terms of representational thinking right um so revenge is manifested in representational thinking
as a product as a result of the will encountering this limit what's required for the crossing over
the the the bridge or crossing over um is to get rid of revenge right and Nietzsche's way of getting
rid of revenge is the thought of that eternal return which in Zarathustra it's really really clear like
you know Zarathustra struggles with this the black snake that goes down his throat right like the
spirit of revenge that he he kind of can't get hold of or has difficulty with in the eternal return
because the does the eternal return mean the eternal return of everything exactly as it is which
would seem to be the total limiting yeah of of the will right um or or conversely does it mean
you know opening up possibilities of the past to the kind of the sense of futurity or active willing
um that the will sees in something like the future yeah you know I mean it's just that's how I get the
language is just the the Deleuzian version of the eternal return is makes so much more sense to me
in that it would be the eternal return of a movement of differentiation or a difference that makes total sense to me
the eternal return of the same if you if you were to think of it under a Hegelian comportment it would be
the return of the will of revenge right that kind of appropriative force that's but that's also not
what Heidegger's after here either so it's just can just the the word same to me it's difficult to wrap
my head around that's right enables the overman in this context you know yeah I think it's the eternal
enduring of the past as a as a as an object as an object of will not as something that is simply past
right correct I mean so I think he gets at this is the full paragraph on 104 that is gonna help us
think through this the most um you know that that the last sentence of the first paragraph says that
deliverance from uh revenge is the will's liberation from what it is revolting from what is revolting to
it uh so that the will can only so that the will can at last be will and so this is I mean I think
this is there's the liberation is the allowance of uh the will to be will rather than the will to be
representation or the will to focus on representation is that next paragraph where he complicates that
at what point is that it was removed uh which is always revolting to the will not when there is no
longer any passing away at all for us men time cannot be removed but what is revolting uh to the will
fades away when the past does not freeze in the mirror it was to confront willing in fixed rigidity
when the past becomes something other than simply has passed or it's gone in that rigid in that rigid
hypothesized sense of past moments past subjects past whatever what is revolting vanishes when the
passing is not just a letting pass in which the past sinks away into the mirror it was the will becomes
right yes the the will becomes free from uh what from what revolts it when it becomes free as will that
is free for the going uh in the passing away but the kind of going that does not get away from the will
but comes back bringing back what is gone the will becomes free from its revulsion against time
against time's mere past when it steadily wills the going and coming this going and coming back of
Everything, it is a making, not making a presence of the past, but making an eternal of the past as well.
An eternal transformability of the past as much as the future.
The past is not simply the frozen thing behind you. It's something that's going to transform, so that's
that the idea of the return of the same then is, I mean, you could say that's the hook to the lose.
Right, well, I I this is where I think to lose and Heidegger diverge a little bit is that I don't think
you know, I I wrote in the margins, you know, the the um the Faulkner quote, you know, "The past is not dead."
It's not the past is not even past, you know, which white tends to have some kind of connotation of
as you were saying, John, that the past isn't fixed. The past is constantly being transformed
in relationship to the present, and the past is constantly transforming the present in relationship
to itself as a kind of specter or something that works on the on the present, and you know there's a
there's that hook that I think you're trying to make to to lose, which would be like that would be a
version of the eternal return of difference, where the past is constantly doing the work of
differentiating the present and always in a transformative way. It's constantly like the
present is differentiating and remaking the past. Yeah, yeah, yes, I don't think that's what's going on
here. I think that there is a stronger sense of the sameness, a year of the eternal willing of the past,
the eternal affirmation of the past, not as past, but as eternally willed will.
And I don't know if that trends, I don't know if that transformative sense is still operative or if
the or if there is a transformative sense that's just operating differently. It would be so much
easier if we had a more dialectical version, meaning like if we didn't talk about the will and we were
able to talk about wills, right? And that's I mean that's what Deleuze does is active force and reactive
force, affirmation and negation, and you put those two different things together and you get like a you
know eight different possibilities of you know um, right, at react reacting negation or acting negation
or whatever, whatever. It just seems like the word the same is just reductive in a way that it doesn't
happen, like it could be the eternal return of the will or the eternal it could just be the eternal
return without of the same. Why do you need that preposition? Why do you need that clause
in there? Like it just I sort of I sort of see, but if I think about it a little hard it's harder because
my initial thought was what what Nathaniel is saying, which is like he needs it to be the eternal
return of the same because that's the only way that the will can will eternally is because the past is
no longer simply behind you it's still to come, right? In a in a way it's not the future but the path
because it's eternally recurring. It's not just behind you so that puts it in front of you
if you're the will and the you here is the will, right? Like it puts the past in front of you as
the eternally it returns to the the same must be the same in order for the will to take it as its
object and it must have the hope that the will that the past will simply stay frozen but will recur
right, but but that really does require it to be the same same, right, you know, well there there are two
if I say same twice does that make it yeah two sams make it different um I mean there are two
things operative here. I mean one is, you know, I don't think it's I think it's with great care that
he turns to Augustine and sort of sets Augustine's orientation to time, and it's important to
the the important note there is that the eternal is not um uh in time. It's not like you know the
eternal isn't forever in time. The eternal operates outside of the movements of time and you know the
eternal becomes very much so caught up in God for Augustine who operates you know not forever in time
but operates independent of time and so for the the eternal return of the the will to become eternal is
to treat it as if it's not operative in time but all how do you make the past not operative in time
and for him I think that's the second move is to think of the same not in terms of the traditional
notion of substance but you know if this is an ontology like the basic ontological unit here as
he's pulling it from showing is though is will right, not substance, not identity, not some content or a
thing, so the the same would have to be it would be the the the eternal return of the same would be
the eternal not in time but sort of like the a timeless affirmation of a will, right, and this yeah
which then substantially or phenomenologically maybe that looks like it maybe it looks like it's the
same all the time or maybe it's perpetually differentiating and transforming. Yeah, I don't know
yeah, I don't know, man, it's I don't either. I also feel like the the sort of I mean, you know, look, the
way that it's presented here is is at this point as a kind of crossing over from the metaphysical view
to something else and that something else seems to me like um i mean yeah you've got two different
versions so for instance to me like one of the things that i hesitate around is is when he goes for
us for us men i mean you just read this passage for us men time cannot be removed and i'm like wait
what didn't you just tell us it didn't drop from the sky and aren't you involved in attempting to
rethink it like i i guess i felt like in reading this i i was just a little bit torn like i'm just
unclear what Heidegger sees himself as offering right like right and may and maybe the problem here is
that he has offered so much that i have read in other arenas that i am not uh cognizant of him as
offering these things like via him or Derrida's version thereof right like well i mean
this is tangential but it kind of points to why like maybe nobody really treats temporality as the
the center of their ontology these days right like time is time is not like the main focus of any
contemporary theorist it's like some version of relations even for Derrida difference is temporal
but it's not he's not always talking about time you know and i feel like just the difficulty of thinking
it and articulating both in ethics and an ontology out of that out of specifically thinking temporality
is so weird and difficult that it just it it makes it hard to latch on to anything
it's not i mean for example to me it's not this thought is not a difficult one for me
um the idea that the past i mean the Faulkner quote like the idea that the past is transforming just as
much as tomorrow right like that's not a difficult thought that the the past isn't simply a given
that it is always being in my terminology performatively you know uh repeated differentially performatively
repeated right like so that that's not hard so i i can say like look of course here's the the problem
is if you see the past is frozen the present is present and the future as we don't yet know um
that seems like an uh like overly schematic uh um you know coarse way of thinking of this
that if if instead you say there is no such thing as the present there is simply the the movement of
present seeing and the past is its own kind of transformative vehicle and the future is another kind of
transformative vehicle that that makes sense to me like i don't find that to be a terribly hard now
but i also sort of take that to be what i've just described to be the metaphysical version that he's
talking about which is like ah it's all sort of perpetual transfer regulated of course like it's not simply
like everything goes but i mean transformative you have coming to be passing away of the past present
and future right they they all are subject to the sort of self-transformational or in our terminology
we'd say like self-defer self-differentiating simply because they're never identical to themselves
right like i mean so i i don't know for me that doesn't seem like a terribly hard thought and it's
no it certainly is different from the notion of the frozen the present the empty future you know
from that image but what you just articulated that's still relatively complex i mean just to say that
time that all the tenses fold into one another you know in certain ways and affect one another and
they aren't simply present or frozen i mean what Heidegger is saying that that i think makes it
another step of difficulty is that the metaphysical orientation reacts against those dynamics
so like the the that vulgar notion of a linear notion of time you know uh is precisely a reaction
that's that revenge against time that we get in the will so it's like and he's saying that we don't
get out of that really so that that's it but like you know isn't my isn't the second version that i
articulate that seems that's what i understand linear time to be yeah you know like i maybe i maybe i have
done something wrong because i feel like that version it's recursive yeah right like in other words there
is still a sort of remaking of the past as one moves into the future but it's still going this way
right the engine of recursion and re-articulation are still all going toward from a past toward the
future so i mean that's to me that sort of recursive notion i feel like and again maybe i'm just not
giving that thought enough credit and maybe that thought is the interesting one that he's pointing
towards i don't i genuinely don't know
you know what matters here i think is how Das Ding thinks its own being and thinks its own
relationship to to being and so there is like that that spirit of revenge that will of revenge and
revulsion against time um is is a major problem and so it would seem to me that in either versions of
those times certainly the the very the coarse version of you know simple past simple present simple
Future is a major problem for you know the spirit of revenge and the major problem of you know the
stagnation of the man and the prevention of of the bridge to the overman, um, that second one
uh, that second version doesn't seem to necessarily lead itself to you know it doesn't seem like
the eternal return of the same is just an ontological given, like it is like the eternal return of difference
is for Deleuze it seems like this is much more an object of affirmation that could or could not lead
to a particular kind of transformation for the human, this particular kind of deliverance, and so
in some ways he's like articulating a line of of hope for the human and the transformation of the
human it's like it sucks to be um operative within a world of representations and the revenge i mean
like representations might do a whole lot for us in terms of their capacity to conceptualize the world
and sort of logistically contend with the world but only through an engine that produces revenge
and resentment as a kind of a byproduct and the only way out of that mode of being is to um
is to re-articulate our relationship to the past as some as something that can be
affirmed eternally yeah and so it is like that's that's what i take the most i mean this is what i have
never seen from Heidegger anywhere else you know not just the ontology of being and time but a kind of
um almost like an ethical or like a um an orientation to something like futurity um vis-a-vis the eternal
return and it's the first this is the first version of the eternal return of the same that i find
interesting and provocative yeah i agree i still prefer the Deleuzian way but like this is this is
at least but i i'm sort of wondering if you follow this out if you don't get to that like um that's
that's my sort of underlying suspicion i don't know i mean let me let me walk through that for a second
like um so for instance when i say this recursive version that i take to be the linear version of time
um the reason i take it to be the linear version of time is i feel like the recursion that's happening
is more of a relationship to history than it is to time itself right which is like yes history our
version of the past and so far as it constitutes us is constantly up for grabs like that just strikes
me as obvious right like i mean i'm not saying that everyone believes that i'm just saying that
doesn't seem like a hard point to make which is our understanding of our past it's not so much the
past it's our histories that that that reconfigures who we are today and who we will be and that that's
sort of transformative that strikes me again to me that's a recursive relationship to time that's much
more of a relationship to history than it is to time itself right time itself still is a past present
and future in a very kind of straightforward way even if one has a recursive relationship to the
historical things that occur in time so that would be a kind of that wouldn't be an ontological
perspectivalism that would be an epistemological perspectivalism that would say like all right time
as pastness has you know is an objective set of relationships and then epistemologically
narratologically whatever we tell different stories about it and those stories affect how we're
capable of of living within the moment and those stories are constantly up for grabs in terms of their
interpretation and construction and deployment but that i don't think would get at this more i think
underlying transition from thinking about the ontology in terms of will yeah well right but
so if you took the next step and you simply said okay what one is doing when one recreates history
is remaking time right like if you if you said it's it's not simply like history isn't just a narrative
laid on top of time right it is it is itself in time so that in rewriting histories or reconceptualizing
or whatever else one is in fact remaking the folding of time itself right so that it's it's not like
there is an underlying linearity that on top of it you know one has this social construction of
uh of history and consciousness at whatever which is you would then have to say that history doesn't
have a privileged relationship to remaking time it's just a one style of oh for sure
for sure yeah i would have no problem with that so um so your sense that so i guess the next step is
your sense of the recursive quality of that i mean does that does that give you the eternal return which
is that every moment is because i mean if he's reading it here is in a sense he's sort of saying
Nietzsche's version of the eternal return of the same is that the same or is that the past will always
again be present right like oh if you're assuming a metaphysics of substance where there are discrete
entities that have been passed that will come again in the future but i don't think that's i think the
so you know i think recurrence is a problem because we think of that very iteratively or like serially
where there's like here's a dot here's a dot here's a dot here's a dot and all those dots are the same
but they're just on different points on the same timeline right i uh the introduction of the concept
of eternal here removes you from that line they're not dots it's like the same thing is is affirmed
eternally so it's not dot dot dot dot it's a single straight line or a beam it's a hum rather than a
so in a sense yeah eternal is a bad word there then for the eternal return it would it would eternal
seems to me i mean it doesn't necessarily but it seems to me that it occurs at every moment in time
is how we think of eternity right and and it sounds like what you're saying is a temporal the a temporal
return of the same yes but but this is i mean this is why that word eternity is important for Heidegger
because eternity at least if you follow like the uh um metaphysics of of time stemming from at least
Augustine eternal eternity has nothing to do with time in fact what marks the eternal is eternal is that
operates outside of time right well yeah it's also maybe a reason why it's not the eternal return of
the similar right i mean it's like it has to be the same because it's an essential relatedness
you know that that transcends any kind of contextual temporal relation this is a structure of being
that persists always
John you're saying like thinking of it in terms of history is relatively easy at least in in within
these theoretical configurations that we're used to the problem for me well yeah is that there's always
that cosmological sense too or like a quantum physics sense which i just don't have any grasp on or like
i don't have a way to orient myself and it always lends towards a kind of thing in itself type of
thinking right where it's like how do we think of time as this thing that's just out there as a
physical entity that's so complex that we simply cannot get a hold on and i think that's not really
what Nietzsche is after exactly either i mean there is that cosmological version of the eternal return of
the same but i just don't really know what to do with that one either um just can you explain to me
what you think is so cool about the Augustine quote because i mean i i don't see like nothing of what
is past will be called back what is of the future is expected as something that will pass by that just
strikes me as like the past is frozen the future will come and pass away but that that's all within
in time that's the less important one it's when and i need to find the passage well let's okay i'm going
to start here at the first full paragraph at one on one or two since in all metaphysics from the
beginning of western thought being means being present being if it is to be thought of that in the highest
distance must be thought as pure presence uh that is in the presence that persists the abiding present
and the steadily standing now medieval thought speaks of Nungsten uh but that is the interpretation
of uh but that is the interpretation of the nature of eternity here let us recall for a moment the
explanation of showing adds to the statement willing is primal being he says that among the predicates
of primal being there are eternity independence of time if all metaphysics think of being as eternity
and independence of time it means precisely this the idea of beings uh sees them as in their being
independent of time the idea of time sees time in the sense of a passing away what must pass away
cannot be the ground of the eternal so that's that distinction of the separation of the
eternal as not being a part of the temporality of a passing away not just a duration in time that
is so long that it never actually passes away so this is in its sense of the eternal as an eternal
present then if all metaphysics thinks of being as eternity and independent of time it means precisely
this the idea of beings see them as in their being and independent of time the idea of time sees time in
the sense of passing away so it's an eternal presence right it's god yeah
exactly and that's exactly what Augustine does with god but it's not i mean that the point would be it's
not a i mean if you continue in the passage it's a critique of that right like it's like that's the
view of presence right so you know but but what about that definition here left unintended of being
itself as being present even as the enduring presence what about being as the being presence and whose
light time was conceived as a passing away and even eternity as the present now is not this definition of being
ruled by the view of presence the presence ruled that is by the view of time and of a time of such a nature
as we can never surmise let alone think with the help of the traditional time concept in other words
it's like that notion of a temporality that constitutes that understanding of eternity ain't the one he's
interested in that's the problem like is that eternity thought as eternal presence because i mean you know
As it and so it continues on to the gloss of being in time it's like what about being in time then must
not one is one as much as the other being as much as time must not both become questionable in their
relatedness and does this not show them that something was left unthought at the very core of the
definition which is regarded so in some ways I feel like what he's critiquing there the notion of being
as presence or eternity or a temporality thought is absolute constant presence right like which I I guess I just was like
well we're not dealing with that because you know to me that's just like who fucking thinks of eternity
as constant presence but obviously Augustine did or others in a certain theological tradition
yeah I mean this is where I just really go to Deleuze's version of the eternal return as well because
the eternity here then especially I'm on uh I don't mean to jump somewhere if you're staying on a page
Nathaniel but on um uh 104 towards the bottom you know he's talking about the will wills its own eternity
and the will wills the it was I mean to me it's like you were willing differentiation that eternity there
is the will's perpetual dissolution and the the the way to get rid of the revenge or the revulsion
against time is transforming the will's relation to itself so willing eternity in that sense means
basically an affirmation of becoming right right I mean in Deleuze's sense in exactly that sense that's
what I'm saying I feel like it heads in that direction it doesn't it doesn't spell out the
steps you're right but I mean that to me I agree with you boo boo that's like that seems to me to
be where it has to be headed yeah um and I mean we we touched on this last episode so I'm not gonna
bring up uh spirit uh extensively here but I mean in the same way he brings up Hegel in the previous
section where he's talking about the the will as a torn consciousness right so like in order to
in order for the will to um kind of approximate its own conditions of actualization and affirm those
it has to affirm the tearing the cutting the the rift that's essential to being right so as opposed to
that eternal presence or of a compulsion towards identity which is the traditional the the will of
revenge the will to eternity or the eternal return of the same has to will perpetual dissolution
it doesn't have to be it doesn't have to be dissolution I mean dissolution but re-articulation
iteration or something right right right yeah yeah the quality of that that movement doesn't have to
be described as right yeah yeah yeah it can't be self-identity which is what people are after I think
like experientially that's that's what he's saying about the the traditional will will's identity
against difference I mean and maybe yeah no no I I get I get that idea and like um that makes more
sense I mean that makes sense to me I think partly like last night I taught Signature Event Context in
my grad class last night and uh and I was just struck by like it maybe I've just been reading Derrida for
too long but like how amazingly obvious it is that of course a mark is never present right like
who would who would be stupid enough to think that a word is simply present as in right there now
obviously a lot of consequences of my claim there follow that aren't often followed out by people
you know so the consequences of non-presence of a word aren't often followed up but nevertheless
that fact strikes me as kind of inarguable like everyone yeah of course that wouldn't work if it
was simply present has to come from somewhere else and be able to go somewhere else like it it has to
another it has to be structurally non-present in order for it to work um and yeah that just strikes
like I'm saying like it just seems kind of obvious again the implications and ramifications of that may not
be obvious but that fact strikes me as obvious and so I feel like I'm starting from a point of non-self
presence you know and so it's like he's working up to uh a point of non-self presence and maybe that's
the problem is that like you know I have been reading Derrida for too long and I'm like okay I got it like
non-self presence you don't have to go through all the moves and when you get there maybe I don't I don't
know yeah yeah I mean one of the issues is that it's a problematic rather than a problem to be
resolved right so like the will to revenge or whatever or resentment is a constitutive dynamic
for Heidegger right it's that being the relation to being is just as much about um concealment as it
is about disclosure right so there's that perpetual movement of concealment and disclosure and so
inherent in our relation to our relationality is a reaction against it is a kind of like reactionary
uh disposition and I think that's the same for Derrida so that's what makes it that's what makes
it difficult for me to see like the the absolute transformation via the figure of the overman or
Derrida uses like joy or humor sometimes or any of that is because yeah it's because it seems like
If it's a constitutive dynamic, there's no there's not really an alternative. There's ways that you can
ponder it and reflect on it, but um, but that's why I mean, so for instance, that's an example of why I
like the version of the overman in Deleuze which is it's just the word for futurity, which of course
means the past as well, right? Like, that's right. That's who the overman is is not a figure, you know, it's
right, right, yeah, always a place marker, and the goal is never to become the overman but to give birth to
it, to prepare the conditions to do the thing, you know? So it's like I think there's just a textual
justification for reading it that way as well. Oh yeah, yeah. I mean, I'm starting I reacted, you remember
when when you taught Thus Spoke Zarathustra, um, Zarathustra? What was it like almost two years
two years ago? It was before the pandemic, and I that was like the last class I took. I was reacting so harshly
against the notion of the overman because of all this, like latent Hegelianism that I didn't even know
I had in me. So I I was just like why would this concept doesn't make any sense to me. It seems
too almost utopian. But now through these different lenses, I'm like it's actually a pretty cool concept.
I mean, I like the way that it's like navigated via Nietzsche even in Foucault this through Heidegger
as well. I mean, it is it's a useful thing to to try to articulate because it's so difficult. I mean, it
gives the notion of a bridge and a direction without a goal. I mean, that's, you know, if you think of it that
way, like that's, you know? So it's not aimless but it doesn't have a telos, and you know that's a, that's
a tricky a tricky thing to conceptualize or to even write.
Did you work through it, Nathaniel? Nathaniel figured out why his what happened in that uh eternal thing?
I I think that you're right that there's definitely a critique of a traditional notion of of time in
those passages, but I I'm not sure that the critique is moving in the direction that as you laid it out.
Is that yes there is a problem in thinking of time simply in terms of presences, and you can't
root? I mean, I think he's pretty clear that look, I can't fix a version of time from the perspective of
being and I can't root as perspective of a sense of being from the perspective of time, that they are
completely intermingled, and it's like hey if you know if you want to learn more about this read my
book called Being and Time. Um, but I don't think that he's simply dismissing then the notion of the
eternal as something that operates not quite according to the logic of a passing away, and you know when
he returns to the eternal return, which like I think it's important that the word eternal is in that
phrase. Um, you know, this is toward the bottom of 104, and we already read part of it but we're talking
about the deliverance of of the will from its revulsion against time, so this is like what two four six
eight ten twelve what four fourteen lines down in that second full paragraph. The will becomes free
the will becomes free from its revulsion against time, against times mere past when it steadily wills
the going and coming, this going and coming back of everything, and that seems to support what you're
saying John. In fact, that's that sentence right there sounds the most like there's a current
transformative differential aspect of it. But then you keep going. The will becomes free from what is
revolting and that it was when it wills the constant recurrence of every it was. The will is delivered
from the revulsion when it wills the constant recurrence of the same. Then the will wills the eternity
of what is willed. The will wills its own eternity. Will is primal being. The highest product of primal
being is eternity. The primal being of beings is the will and the eternal recurrent willing of the eternal
recurrence of the same. The eternal recurrence of the same is the supreme triumph of metaphysics of the
will that eternally wills its own willing. Like I there I'm just getting I'm still getting this sense of
a revaluation of the past and the revaluation of all metaphysics in terms of wills and let's just think
about like the will is nothing more than a direction force of of a becoming that has more or less
affinities with some things than than it does. I mean it's desire desire for desire, yeah. Desire and
the delusions desire that produces consciousness. Yeah, right, exactly. Desires that produce a consciousness as
an effect, exactly. But anyway, that that that it would have to be a con a continued a in many ways a temporal
affirmation of of will as primary being that isn't that can never have just passed away that doesn't
operate in the passing away of presences, which is why this is the deliverance of revenge of a revolver
but how is that not I mean because so for instance like it to me the direction that the Augustine
quote was going is say you know like Augustine desires and a sense of eternity that is atemporal
because it is in a constant state of presence. To me Heidegger's intervention here is saying
There is no constant state of presence, right? It it is only coming to be, passing away. And so the wills
The desire of the will to be eternal is to will the capacity of the transformation of the past just as
much as the transformation of the future. So that's where, okay, so that opens something up for me, right.
There you're totally right about Augustine, is that because the eternal is more or less conflated with
God, and God is sort of like this unifying self-presence that then becomes the source for the
all the becoming of the world is a fallen version of God's total absolute self-presence.
But you're right, yeah, I mean, that that's completely the case, but I still think, and I think he's
problematizing that notion of the eternal as pure presence identical to God, but I think he's holding
on to a sense of the eternal as something that doesn't operate according to a logic of
temporal passing, but it's temple presence. I think it does operate as passing away, but not a presence that
is passed away. It is nothing but passing away, right? Like if you remove presence from that equation of
coming to be, passing away, you remove the middle point which is the present, right, instead of so because
to me what's happening in in this line of thinking is that we're kind of hypostasizing presence and
making it the absolute transcendent term, and instead I think what he's doing is extracting it out and
saying it's all coming to be, passing away. And so if you think of the will only in terms of those things
and never in terms of a presence, then it doesn't encounter the past as a limit anymore, right? Because
it's the past is not a presence you would have to be, right? So passing away would have to be made
eternal, right? Coming to be, passing away, become becoming. I mean, that's what you know, boo boo was
saying a little bit ago, like becoming is everything, like it's if it's if it's all becoming then the
affirmation of being, I mean, again we'd have to be careful because becoming only has meaning in
relationship to a certain understanding of being, so you'd have to, you know, but you'd call it
difference, right? Or you'd call it iterability or you'd call it desire or whatever else. That what
we're talking about is removing that notion of presence as the undergirding principle, not not
sort of transcendentalizing it to becoming this sort of absolute term of eternity, but separating it from
so that all presence is only constituted by the coming to be, passing away, or iteration or
difference or, you know, whatever those terms are, so that allows the will. Are you telling me that you
two were continuing to have this conversation while I was deeply reading? Yeah, we did. We actually
you're gonna have to go back a little because we figured all this shit out, like we nailed it down.
Like boo boo boo, like wrote the end to his dissertation. I mean, he's just like he's like, okay, I'm done.
I wrapped, I wrapped up the style book, and yeah, yeah. How long was I out? What eternity is you and your time
fixation on the present, man. Yeah.
It was both in eternity, and it was only five minutes. Yeah, oh no, this is not recorded time, you people, and
you're reliant on technology. This was X, this is extra temporal, but not because it's a presence.
Can I move us in a slightly different, I mean, it's still the it's still the same question, but just in a
slightly different milieu? Um, I'm on 109 when he starts talking about uh the two sutterfuges or
basically I guess misreadings of the eternal return. Um, and he kind of suggests I might be, I might be
also misreading Heidegger's exposition of these misreadings, but he seems to suggest that the eternal
return not only as a concept but also possibly as an ontological phenomenon, uh, what is historically
located that with Nietzsche's thinking and perhaps with the onset of industrialization modernization
whatever, that that's when the eternal return came onto the scene, and I'm wondering what you guys think of
that suggestion because that that kind of relates to a quasi Foucodian notion of like, right, the the break
in the image of thinking and in the kind of being when you get to modernity that for Heraclitus
there was no not only was there not a concept of the eternal return of the same that wasn't a
phenomenon uh back then. Well that's why he puts Parmenides and Heraclitus next to each other, right?
If Parmenides is the thinker of absolute being and Heraclitus is the thinker of absolute becoming
right, like that that's where the sort of link of those two and that's why he's really interested
in Parmenides especially because it's like hey here's what absolute being is, total Heraclitus in in
that sense, you know, um yeah but I love, I mean this is just an aside before we get to that because
it's on the same page. I love that rereading that chunk from Zarathustra uh at the very top where
he's like, we've created the heaviest thought, which is the eternal return of the same, now what we have
To do is invent a being who can affirm that right like another it ain't human right like we the
human came up with the thought but we can't fucking affirm that thought because it's just too heavy
right it means all the boredom all the banality all the tedium all the everything uh also also
returns we have to figure out something capable of selecting but for the for the two objections like
the second objection is easy right like the second objection is that hey we can find this thought
this is just the thought of a cycle we can find this thought everywhere right um and so there's
nothing terribly new about this thought and he's like but you know and i agree with him on this what
good is it supposed to do us to ascertain that some thought can already be found in Leibniz or
already in Plato if their thought is left in darkness as the as this thought is allegedly
clarified by such references right so in other words it just becomes a way of degrading or denigrating
a line of thinking without engaging it you know i mean and so so i get that part as well is like you
know um we still haven't thought or here's a way or maybe it's here's a way of avoiding that thought
where he says the thought of the eternal recurrence remains veiled right and it's veiled in two ways one of
the ways is because people just say oh it reminds me of Leibniz and and again that's not to say that it's
not i mean it's it's just but that doesn't necessarily go anywhere it's it's very common
think about to me this is the whole new materialism indigenous critique
right like is exactly that is like oh that was already done by indigenous people it's like well
that's a way of avoiding the question right like that's a very like what is the thinking
like lay out the thinking but that's not done right because that's the work that's the hard part
so that's the the second one the the first one is um Nietzsche's uh Nietzsche's thought of the eternal
turn of the same as a kind of mysticism and doesn't belong it's not properly philosophical because
it's self-differentiation yeah so as concerns the first side of huge according to which Nietzsche's
thought blah blah the coming age in which the essence of modern technology will come to light
might have taught man that a thinker's essential thoughts do not become in any way less true
simply because we fail to think them i mean so that's his way of saying you know again that's
just another way of dismiss i mean that's what i take it that's another way of not thinking with
the thinker you know is is to say well that's just sort of a mystical thing that's not properly
philosophical which frankly i mean think about how a lot of you know analytic philosophy
engages or doesn't engage Nietzsche as being too literary too poetic right i mean to me that's the
equivalent there it's like this is not a rigorously philosophical concept and he's like yeah that's
fine but um that's just a way of avoiding engaging with the thinking just like saying it has precursors
so to me those are like two strategies or two tactics for not thinking with the thinker
um again that i sort of agree with now i i also think in both cases one can follow those out
and one could think eternal return via Leibniz and one could think you know Nietzsche's eternal return
through poetry or you know mysticism or whatever else right like one could do that it might be
valuable to do so right i mean you know but it's true he does he does you know very much link this to
the coming age um in which the essence of modern technology will come to light
right meaning it will reveal itself yeah as the sort of the the s well the essence of modern
technology as the what representational standing reserve you know right yeah and he emphasizes
somewhere back in the beginning that Nietzsche is not just an extraordinary thinker he is insofar as
language speaks us he is a vessel for a way of thinking that was enabled in that particular
historical era right so like the reason that Nietzsche is Nietzsche is because he was in that moment
like if you if you put Nietzsche back in Heraclitus's time it's no longer Nietzsche
there's not the same thinking the not the same character of thought at all right and that's the way
i mean to me that's the that's the importance of thinking time is thinking the sort of irreducible
embeddedness in temporality that is not simply present right like that like hanging on to both
parts of that the irreducible embeddedness in a moment and also the non-determinant quality of
that moment but i frankly i think and especially since our meeting recently it's like Hegel Hegel can
give you that although there's it's too teleological in Hegel but nevertheless it can give you that sense of
like look to be in a you know Plato wouldn't work without the pre-Socratics
right, it wouldn't make sense without a certain precursor, and then Aristotle doesn't work without
Plato, and that, you know, um, so all of those relationships are absolutely necessary. I mean
I I think all the time just in terms of my own personal life, having nothing to do with the history of
philosophy, it's like I am so fucking thankful to live in a historical moment where Nietzsche wrote
Deleuze wrote Derrida wrote, like I'm I'm just like what would my life be? It would be different
and I wouldn't know it as missing that, but given the one that I'm in I'm so like truly like when I go to
like when I go to Thanksgiving dinner or something I think like one of the things that I'm really thankful
for is to have lived after these people wrote, you know? Really? Yeah, you know I mean could you imagine
a John Muckelbauer that hasn't read read those like what would that person even be? I mean it would be
so I I mean you know it wouldn't make sense to say he's still a John, it wouldn't make sense to me
not anymore. I mean certainly. I mean I've thought about this a lot recently as I'm getting older and
whatnot, like you know I didn't have to go this particular direction. It could have happened other
ways and to that extent those things would have because those things that I read even very early
would have just been like oh you know this childish thing, you know how you create the narrative of your
own development, but that's from a vantage point which is like okay who given who I am now here are the
things that were really formative at that time, but if I if it was a different who I am now those things
would be ancillary secondary and I may not even remember them, right? Like it just could have gone
in different ways, like I'm certain of that. I mean I have no doubt whatsoever. Isn't it weird how much
comfort it gives people to think like oh I was always destined to do this thing, or you know I you
know I I I couldn't imagine myself doing anything else. I mean like that that to me is weird. I mean I
I guess I kind of get that the anxiety just because you know thinking that I could have broken in a
different direction at frankly any moment in any part of my life in any direction. Now granted some of
those directions are more or less likely because you know the affinities are greater or stronger, right?
But still that there is in no way shape or form like some essence of Nathaniel that is going to
emerge and for a lot of people that's scary because it's sort of like the thing that I identify with the
most is completely contingent, so much so that even myself isn't enough to don't you have like for
instance I would say for me now, now meaning starting at age 52, I would say it now like now I would say
I feel much more of a sense of I would never call it destiny but like a calling, like there's a thing
that I'm meant to do right, um, and it's and of course that's because of a build-up of a whole
a whole lot of training and everything else like it's I don't think it's metaphysical in that way, I
think it's simply like given that I've spent, you know, 30-ish years doing this kind of thing I now feel
compelled to do this kind of thing, right? Um, so I when I understand people's sense of that destiny
thing I think they just felt that earlier, right? Like the feeling that I have now, like look I'm not
and I'm way comfortable with this I'm not going to be good at a lot of things. There's a lot of like
for instance golf. I like playing golf and I'm relatively good at it and I work I I practice
but I simply do not care enough to practice enough to get really good at it. I just don't
right? And so like from this point on I I couldn't be a great golfer. I just couldn't and and the reason
I couldn't is not because I don't have to because I don't want to, right? It doesn't matter to me, like
I want to write cool shit and I want to produce interesting intellectual ecologies. I want to do that
so I have I feel called to do that kind of thing. I recognize that I feel called to do that kind of
thing not because god's speaking to me or something but simply because I've been doing that kind
of thing and it's what I enjoy I've found the source of joy and I'm just saying like you know
I think for me it was somewhere in my mid-40s where I started to feel like okay I'm doing what I should
be doing right like I I am in the right course not because there was some pre-ordained course but
because I was built into this kind of you know this type these series of practices and it found my
place or whatever else but I think that other people said your constitution right that's fine but I think
that other people have that when they're 16 years old or they can have it when they're 16 years
old or or eight right like so to me it's no different right like it's I mean that's how
I understand it which is like hey I'm called to in the sense that like I desire this more strongly
than anything else like I would rather be doing this thing than anything else, so like tie the woods with
golf i mean to take the golf analogy, it's like everyone always understood it's like, oh, his dad must have
forced him to practice when he was a kid. That's completely untrue. It was exactly the opposite. This kid
wanted to do that 24/7. His parents had to make him go to school and go to sleep, right? And he he's just
had that insistent desire for that series of practices his whole life, right? Like, and that's i mean to me
that's how people end up being great at things is because they figure out what that draw or drive or
desire is when they're 12, 13, 14 years old, not when they're 45, right? Well, but i think you would have
to modify it. It's not that they figure it out. It's that they coalesce, yeah, in a particular way that's
not like it was. That's right. You're absolutely right. It's not simply like it was there and they finally
became cognizant of it, yeah. They got immersed in the series of practices and networks and ecologies that
would formulate them to be to be that person, yeah, and it just happens sort of like, and it and it turns
into not in a negative aspect but a compulsion. You are compelled to do this thing regardless of
the rest of your circumstances. You have to get it done. You have to do it every day